this is jaco podcast number 237 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening so lots of
dynamic things happening in the world
right now and when there are lots of
dynamic things happening leaders have to
make things happen
leaders have to assess have to decide
have to plan and since all of us are
going through these dynamics scenarios I
wanted to I wanted to touch on something
today it's called troop leading
procedures and the version that I'm
going to cover is from an army
techniques publication or Field Manual
three tack 21.1 which is which is the
name of that is infantry rifle company
and its a giant manual 500 or something
pages which we're not gonna go through
all that because there's an appendix in
it and appendix B is planning and
preparing and it's look it's interesting
I've planned a lot of things in my life
and I've been in charge of a lot of
planning in my life I've been very lucky
from that perspective and I was planning
things before I knew any of this stuff
and I learned a lot of lessons along the
way from from that and then as I started
to reflect back and once I started kind
of officially learning about how to plan
I would look back and see how things
made sense and see some things that I
would overlook some things that I didn't
overlook some things that the doc the
the documents overlook so thinking about
this and this is actually based on this
massive process in the army or in the
military called the military
decision-making process which is this
absolutely granular way to go through
every possible element of a decision of
a big decision of how you're gonna plan
something so that is meant for higher
higher elements
above the company right so that's meant
for a battalion brigade division you
know when you have a whole staff of
people that their job is to do these
type of long decision-making processes
so this right here is meant at the
company level you know 100 guys 150 guys
three platoons worth of guys that's what
this is aimed at and there's definitely
some things in here to pay attention to
so that you know we can we can see if
we're missing things see if there's
things we can add see if there's some
things we can we can take away from this
that will help us lead and plan and make
better decisions and I'm not gonna even
go into massive depth even this
subsection even this appendix it has a
lot of really granular information and
that's one thing you know the army does
doctrine very well and they go they get
they get into it and they will get
granular you will not miss anything if
you follow their doctrine but a lot of
it is very specific to the military but
it's even worth looking at you can get
this on the interwebs just as a PDF or
whatever this whole document you can
check this out
and it will give you some indication of
the level of granularity that they're
planning to but we're not gonna dive
into all that I'm gonna try and keep it
to the elements in here that are for the
most part universally applicable in in
anyone that's planning so here we go
planning a preparation appendix D from
fm3 tac 21.1 planning is a process by
which the company commander translates a
visualization into a specific course of
action
for preparation and execution focusing
on expected results it's interesting to
even think of the fact that what you're
doing as the leaders you're taking this
vision and you're turning it into an
executable plan so just that right there
can help people and I'll tell you how if
you don't have a vision you're not going
to come up with a plan yeah so the whole
process is taking your visualization
your vision and turning it into an
actionable course of action things that
you can actually do just think about
that from your daily life perspective
right if
you don't have a vision of what your
days gonna be like that day is not gonna
have a plan behind it you're not gonna
have a course of action for that day
yeah so out of the gate we're already
learning sentence one we're in the game
planning helps create helps the
commander create and communicate a
common vision and a shared understanding
between subordinate leaders and unified
action partners boy that's a weird way
of saying team right unified action
partners actually as good I was saying
that in kind of an insulting way but
then I kind of got into it right I kind
of transitioned there in the process of
saying it
this guy's not my teammate he's my
unified actions partner oh yeah see
where we're coming from that's under you
know the Army will add some they'll make
up some some things like that yeah team
isn't good enough we're going unify -
yeah it's cliche we're not talking about
the team is just you know you're playing
games unified action partners planning
results in an order that synchronizes
the action of forces in time space and
purpose to achieve objectives and
accomplish the missions that's a very
verbose way of making that statement
right we know what planning does I'm not
even gonna read that sentence together
is a bit much the commander relies on
intuitive decision-making and direct
contact with subordinate leaders to
integrate activities when circumstances
are not suited for true bleeding
procedures so what does that mean at a
certain point you're not doing all this
detailed planning you're relying on your
relationship your intuitive nests and
understanding and communicating with the
subordinate leaders so you don't get to
do this all the time that's understood
I'm gonna talk about three different
types of planning parallel planning
collaborative planning and distributed
planning parallel planning allows each
Ashkelon to make maximum use of the time
available and the way it does that is
that you let's say I was the boss and
you were the subordinate and I said hey
echo we're gonna go film something in
Texas that's all you need to know and
you're gonna start coming up with a plan
you don't just wait for me to say hey
we're going to Dallas we're going to
film this we're gonna be there for this
today you go okay we're going to Texas I
know that start coming up with a plan
I'm gonna need batteries I'm gonna need
SD cards see I'm kind of doing your job
for the other thing so parallel planning
you want to tell people what's happening
so they can start to plan collaborative
planning is commanders subordinate
commanders to staff and other partners
sharing information knowledge
perceptions ideas concepts regardless of
physical location throughout the
planning process obviously right we are
gonna work together to come up with a
plan up and up and down the chain of
command we're working and then
distributed planning allows the
commander and staff members to execute
planning from different locations
okay no factor goes into some detail
about about parallel planning here
two or more s Ilan's planning for the
same operation sharing information
sequentially through warning orders and
higher headquarters prior to higher
headquarters publishing their operation
plan or their opera order well that's
what I just said you're not waiting
until I give you the full detailed
timeline of what we're doing in Texas to
go film this video mmm I'm just telling
you we're going to Texas and you're kind
of gonna start thinking of how you're
gonna get it done you don't need to know
much more than that
parallel planning hinges on a shared
understanding of the situation pause for
a moment that is important because if we
don't have a shared understanding of the
situation we could come up with totally
different parallel plans if you think
we're going to Texas to film you know a
podcast but I know that we're going to
film an action sequence right you're
bringing different equipment yes so I
need to give you a shared understanding
of the situation the company commander
cannot finalize the company order until
the battalion completes it their order
so at some point you have to know
everything that I know at some point you
have to know exactly what it is we're
trying to make happen so that makes
sense okay
and and so we look at them I'm skipping
through a bunch of stuff here but I want
to jump into the actual true pleading
procedures which it says are a dynamic a
dynamic process
used by small unit leaders to Anam
analyze a mission develop a plan prepare
for an operation troop leading
procedures extend the MD MP conducted at
battalion level with its coordinating
staff to accompany level so the MD MP is
the thing I talked about military
decision-making process these procedures
an able company level leaders to
maximize available planning time while
developing effective plans and preparing
the company for a mission troop leading
procedures consist of eight steps the
troop leading procedure step sequence is
not rigid so you're gonna get a sequence
of how you're gonna plan but it's not it
doesn't stay that way all the time
the commander modifies the sequence to
meet mission situation and time
available some steps are done
concurrently while others may go on
continuously throughout the mission the
troop leading procedure steps are as
follows - step one receive the mission
and I'll go ahead and just pause right
there that's something that you know
when people think of when you win let's
say someone like yourself echo Charles
when you hear that I know what you're
thinking you're thinking of ninety-eight
percent of the movies that you've seen
about the military which is you know the
troops are sitting around the board and
in comes the commander when the
commander says okay gents here's the
next mission right that's like the
common thing am I wrong you're not wrong
and that does happen but it's not well
in the SEAL Teams it's not normal it's
not the norm the norm is the team itself
the platoon the task unit the troop is
developing the information they're
finding out so they're kind of making
the mission
producing the machine gathering the into
all those things are happen but it does
happen sometimes where you literally
receive the mission hey here is what you
need to go do so that's step number one
receive the mission or I guess we would
say either receive the mission or or
confirm the mission or select the
mission because you'll have multiple
missions that you're trying to bring to
fruition so when you finally decide on a
mission or you receive a mission that's
be the two things I would say that's
number one number two issue a warning
order which we'll get into number three
make a tentative plan number four
initiate movement number five conduct
reconnaissance number six complete the
plan number seven issue the order number
eight supervise and refined okay
troop leading procedures begin with the
company commander bring in when the
company commander receives the first
indication of an upcoming mission and
continues throughout the operational
process so this whole time you're sort
of supposed to be and then one of the
key words here that they use is refine
you're supposed to be refining this plan
all the time
that never stops troop leading for troop
leading procedures comprise a sequence
of actions to help cut the commander use
available time effectively and
efficiently to issue orders and execute
operations normally the first three
steps which is receive the mission give
the warning order and make a tentative
plan of troop leading procedures occur
in order the tasks involved in some
actions such as initiate movement issue
the warning order and conduct
reconnaissance may recur several times
during the process
the last step supervisor find occurs
throughout so there you go a couple
other things to highlight from this
section attention exists between
executing current missions and planning
for future missions
the company commander must balance both
that happens all time in business
happens all the time in any environment
right you've got what we're doing right
now and you need to pay attention to
what we're doing right now and you also
need to think about what we're going to
be doing
I hate to say this but often times it is
necessary to bifurcate between who's
planning what's happening right now and
who's planning what's happening in the
future so for instance for instance in
the SEAL Teams you'll end up with
someone who is the operations officer
who's kind of handling what we're doing
right now and you have future operations
officer who's handling what is coming
down the pipe so that is something to
think about
if you don't have the manpower to do
that a good thing to do is to a lot a
certain amount of time every day to say
okay look we're in the firefight today
we got stuff going on we know we need to
get that handled but I'm gonna take an
hour after lunch before lunch I'm gonna
sit down for two hours during lunch with
my team we're gonna talk about what's
going on in the future because it can be
very hard to get that stuff done it's
well I shouldn't say that it can be very
hard to actually pay attention to what's
going on in the future when you have a
lot of activity happening right now in
front of our face so you need to think
through that you need to pay attention
to it the commander and subordinate
leaders begin troop leading procedures
when they receive an initial warning
order or receive a new mission as each
subsequent order arrives the commander
modifies assessments updates tentative
plans and continues to supervise and
assess preparations the big difference
there they're talking about you know
your boss keeps giving you additional
information for us we would be waiting
well the thing that would be driving us
to make adjustments is intelligence that
would be coming in oh we're getting this
information oh we're getting some other
information so that's what's making us
adjust and adapt our plan as we work the
commander uses true bleeding procedures
when working alone or with a small group
to south solve tactical problems
obviously risk management occurs
continuously throughout troop leading
procedures with varying emphasis on
different steps of different I'm so
you've always got to be assessing risk
mm you're always gonna be assessing risk
in fact I was talking to a client the
other day and we were talking about risk
assessment
and I I made some statement or whatever
I we were going through some problem and
I was talking about the risk involved
and they said something along the lines
I'd be like it seems like you it seems
like you're very school didn't you know
risk evaluation or whatever some
statement like that and I said yes well
you know my entire job before who was
doing risk evaluation and risk
assessment and mitigating risk that's
what you're doing that's what that's
what the planning of a mission is if we
if we insert this way waters our risk
what's the benefit if we insert the
other way what's the risk how do we
mitigate it you know that's what you're
doing for every phase of an operation
and so and that is what you should be
doing hmm
every move that you make has some level
of risk and they go through the risk
management steps step one identify the
hazard step to assess the hazards step
three develop controls and make risk
decisions step four implement controls
and then supervise and evaluate and
that's there's a there's other stuff in
here on risk assessment but that's the
the fundamentals of what they're telling
you to do and then it says this troop
leading procedures are not a
hard-and-fast set of rules some actions
may be performed simultaneously or an
order different than shown and they have
a big chart they've got it it's actually
a big chart with all kinds of little
arrows and boxes and showing you a
flowchart of how you're making decisions
cool to look at interesting interesting
to look at and it's a good thing to look
at and sort of maybe overlay the types
of decisions that you have to make and
one thing that I'll say that
it is something to pay attention to is
time time is the hardest you know you
know I was I was talking the other day
on EF online and I was explaining to
people that very seldom do you make a
final decision right so I'm talking like
this is legit in life it's very seldom
that you have to make a final decision
like this is it when you make this
decision that's it you don't get another
chance so for instance you know
inaudible
to go back and undo it and even
something as Extreme as if you have to
fire somebody yeah like let's say you
got if let's say you know you work for
me and I decide you you know you're not
doing a good job and I fire you even
that if I could look back in two weeks
and contact you in say hey listen I
think I made a bad call like there's a
there's a way out of it right it's and
so many decisions are like that even a
decision as massive as on a personal
level
oh we're gonna buy a house seems like
this final decision actually you can
sell that house you know you can get
back out of that so there's a lot of
decisions that we make that seem like
they're final decisions but they're
actually not
and the reason that I was talking about
this is because if you and I are
discussing something if you and I are
negotiating something chances are it's
not the last negotiation we're gonna
have if you if you want if you're
pitching me your plan on how to do
something and I'm I'm fighting back with
my plan chances are we're gonna we're
gonna have another opportunity to go
through what plan and how the plan is
executed so for me to think if I agree
to your plan and now I'm like well okay
yeah I'm agreeing with that closed plan
now my opportunity influence is totally
gone it's not true actually you know if
I agree yeah you know when I co your
plan seems pretty good let's go with it
mm-hmm well we're gonna it's not just
we're going to take your plan at that
moment and execute it right we're now
okay let's go through the
planning process we're a look at what
how we're actually gonna do it and we
can make little adjustments so very
often our negotiations are not final and
our decisions are not final
I don't know you know what what's a
final decision that you have to make in
life right there's getting a tattoo even
that's not finally you and get that
thing removed I think it hurts a lot
apparently it's a little bit more than
the actual tattoo yeah from what I hear
so and I think it leaves a scar right
yeah a little bit okay so that's a
that's closer to a permanent decision
yeah but generally we're making
decisions that are that that have and
this is actually what I said I said when
you can you actually want to make
decisions that are open-loop meaning
we're not gonna make the closed decision
if I can avoid it
now if I have to make it I make it but
if I can leave an opening on the
decision then I will because that gives
me some room to maneuver and and
backpedal and maybe it was the wrong
choice and I made it yeah you'd be
hard-pressed really nothing you kind of
think about it to find a decision I mean
of course the obvious ones if you're
gonna kill somebody or something like
that or do something like illegal where
it's gonna be like right you're gonna go
to jail for that or so you know that
kind of stuff but yeah it's like there's
always a sort of like you couldn't
maneuver your way back into the you know
a different decision and what's
important about this is if you go into
something thinking that you want to
maintain the ability to maneuver then
that is a good attitude to have yeah so
I always try and make small decisions
yes and also trying to make the least
amount of final decisions that I can now
look are do you do you get two points in
some situations where you do it yes you
do and when you do you assess it and
then you make your final decision you
move forward the reason that I'm saying
all this is there is something that is
non-negotiable
that has no mercy and you can never go
back on time time
and the way we treat time sometimes
oddly enough it's the thing that we act
as if it's the good you know as if we're
gonna have more time or we can get that
time back
yeah we Nageotte we think it's it's a
negotiated bowl thing and the bottom
line is it's not and so the reason I
bring this up is because they talk about
it and it's one of the key points of
assessing planning is assessing the time
that you have available and so often I
see companies I see people in business
I see planning or in the SEAL Teams
people used to make this mistake and you
see people make this mistake with their
life which is time is the one thing that
there's no negotiation on and once you
let it go there's literally no possible
way to get it back it's gone it's gone
you can try and recover some of it by
picking up the pace here cut in the
corner there you can try and recover
some of that time but let's face it it's
gone if you sleep in and you wake up
late you can still get a workout in you
compress it to somebody but you didn't
get the phone right you didn't get that
full workout so you have this is if
there's anything to take away from this
if there's one thing that you need to
kind of pay attention to above all it's
how you utilize your time because it's
quick all right step one now we're
getting to step one which is receive the
mission step one in true pleading
procedures the commander determines the
company's mission and assesses the time
available to accomplish the mission
there you go that's the first thing
you've got to do and this is what school
they go into this little section here
when they talked a little bit about how
you receive the mission but then they
say here's some things that you can do
in this first step conductive
confirmation brief to the battalion
commander to verify an understanding of
the battalion commanders intent so
that's good you you've got something to
do let's confirm with the upper echelon
to make sure we understand what they
want initial assessment you knock that
out and then it goes goes into these
last three
bullet points which all have to do with
what I just talked about which I put a
star next to each one of these because I
was thinking about this conducts an
initial planning time analysis to
identify critical times in the time line
two analyzes the time the company
commander has if the company has
available and three prepares an initial
time line this is so important I'm gonna
tell you want to know about well I mean
I do this a lot but one time this that
this is very obvious to me I did this
didn't really think about it but we were
at one of the musters and there's a lot
of stuff going on as like one of the
early musters there was a lot of chaos
going on and actually this was this
wasn't probably this is maybe like
mustard like four or five so there's
things happening but we're starting to
understand a little bit better and
everyone's got you know where we're
meeting and the whole team's there and
and I can see I'm like wait a second I
don't feel comfortable with where we are
right now and then I said all right
here's what's going on
we're gonna meet it this time for this
we're gonna meet at this time for this
everyone's got to have their brief
Dawn's by this and just put out a
timeline and all of a sudden everyone's
locked into position everyone knows
what's happening we know how much time
we have we get it yeah if you don't do
that as a leader that time disappears it
disappears and you cannot get it back it
is impossible to get back so when you
get a tasking of some kind the very
first thing you should do is just do a
good analysis of the amount of time and
you know what you might want to start
looking at your days and your weeks like
that too yeah cuz it's slipping this is
then it says the most important element
of a company's a warning order is the
initial timeline for planning they're
just beating this down a warning order
this is a cool thing to know a warning
order is a preliminary notice of an
order of action to follow so this is
Whitsitt basically a heads-up mmm it's a
heads-up hey this is what's going on
this is what we got going on this is
what we expect to have happening it's
kind of like me saying you hey echo we
just got a call we're going to Texas we
got to do a filming mm-hmm that's a
warning order yeah hey echo we're going
to Texas probably in two weeks we're
gonna record a podcast there with a
guest and you're like okay cool
you don't need to know anything I mean
you you can
a lot of initial planning that's what a
warning order is it's it's important to
put that together because it gives
people a heads up here's some of the
things inside of a warning order mission
or nature of the operation time and
place for issuing the operation order so
I'm gonna give you the final order at
this time task organized the units units
or elements participating in the
operation so I was like hey echo we're
gonna go down there but also good deal
Davis coming with us okay cool so now
you know you got camera right so you
already know who else is involved in
this situation
oh and JP's meeting us there late you
know what I'm saying we're gonna add
what you're gonna know everyone you're
dealing with reconnaissance and
surveillance to initiate hey we're gonna
be in the Austin area
can you see what some possibilities are
for us to record it you see where I'm
going with us locations yeah locations
you're doing a little recon you're gonna
get on Google Maps you know look for
various hotel see what kind of
conference rooms they have security
missions to initiate that's very
militaristic thinking if we're gonna be
doing an operation sometimes we got to
shut down outside communication we gotta
we gotta start doing our weapons testing
every day so if we do it the day before
people know us we're gonna do some
security precautions movement to
initiate if you had to fly in someone
you start that movement information
requirements what do you need to know
essentially commanders critical
information requirement which I've been
taught I've actually been talking about
about that one a decent amount I've been
talking about that one decent amount
because as we went into kovat 19 this
lockdown that the world has been in a
lot of companies and businesses that we
work with all of a sudden were not
coming in to work there were not
co-located everyone's working from home
they're working on computers and
sometimes they would feel like I would
have leaders asking me well you know I
don't I don't know what my team is doing
and I don't know if they're doing the
right things and so I talked about some
methods to make sure that they are doing
the right things without micromanaging
two things one of them is an execution
checklist meaning okay I'll be at this
location at this time working on
by this time I'll be working on this
next thing by I'll be at this other job
site by this time I'll be this done with
this much of the project by this time so
you know where they're at
hmm the other thing is this commanders
critical information requirements which
means if something happens inside these
required elements you tell me about it
hmm
so for instance in Ramadi you know if we
had troops in contact
my tactical operations center knew to
come and tell me we had troops in
contact if we obviously if we had a guy
wounded if we had civilian casualties
there was things that guys knew come and
tell me immediately and to be honest
with you as time went on we modified
those because eventually it was like hey
the guys are gonna be in contact if
they're in the field - be in contact let
me know if it lasts for more than 15
minutes or something like that because
otherwise they're they're contacting me
all the time and it's just not worth it
next one is essential element of
friendly information this is knowing
where your friendly forces are planning
and preparation instructions specific
tasks not addressed by unit standard
operating procedures that's an important
one so if I tell you hey echo we're
gonna go film a podcast and by the way
it's gonna be underwater you go okay
that's not normal it was outside the
norm you got to get a case housing
housing this yeah you got to get a hot
waterproof housing and last thing most
important timeline for the operation so
there are some things that you put in
the warning order next thing is make a
tentative plan in a time constrained
environment
commander typically develops only one
course of action I don't even know if
it's Potter they say that I don't even
know if it's possible to only develop
one course of action because when you
look at a problem you automatically come
up with multiple ways to solve it so you
automatically come up with multiple
courses of action I guess maybe they say
develop maybe that's the key word that
I'm that I'm not focused on because you
can come up with three courses of action
but only actually develop one meaning go
into it a little bit more so I guess
that does make sense
the the commander does not wait for a
complete up or before
starting to develop a tentative plan
this is important and is two parts of
this that make it important when you
develop a tentative plan first of all
you don't want to wait too long to try
and develop it in second of all you once
you start to develop it you don't want
to go all the way because you're gonna
waste time when you don't actually know
so you might get told hey you're gonna
hit a target in this area well we think
it's this building right so you start
coming up with a plan tentative plan
that you start going further and you
haven't heard anything yet
and you get all the way to where you're
actually developed the perfect plan for
this particular and then they go oh
that's sorry wrong building I actually
wrong block actually we're one town over
so you develop this whole plan wasted a
bunch of time spun everybody up when
what you should have said is hey guys
we're gonna do a direct action mission
get your gear ready get some sleep
I'll let you know when it develops
further so now everyone gets their gear
ready maybe they get a little sleep now
we get more granular detailed
information we can take that next step
in planning moving to mission analysis
the commander conducts mission analysis
to develop situational understanding
which is the product of applying
analysis and judgment to relative
information to determine the
relationship among the operational
admission variables to facilitate
decision-making and to confirm what the
company must do to accomplish the
mission that's a big sentence what does
it mean situational understanding you
want to know what's happening you want
to know what's happening and figure out
what it is you need to do to accomplish
the mission oh we're going on the on a
mission and there is a giant river that
we're gonna need to get across okay well
we know we're gonna have to do a river
crossing
okay got it oh there's a cliff that we
need to climb okay so now we got to come
up with a way to climb a cliff so
there's you're looking at this situation
overall and figuring out what it's gonna
take to get through that situation
oh there's you know of a gate or a bit
or a fence around we need to find a way
to get over through under around the
fence okay so you're figuring out what
you're gonna need to make this happen
and accomplish the mission that's the
mission analysis mission analysis
answers for questions
that become inputs to developing a
course of action these questions are
what is the company's mission what is
the current situation how does the
company accomplish the mission and what
are the risks analyzing the mission
variables is a continuous process the
commander constantly receives
information from the time the planning
begins through execution what is the
company's mission what is the current
situation how does the company
accomplish the mission and what are the
risks those the questions you're asking
yourself to figure out a course of
action and this is where it might seem
like those are real obvious in fact I'll
you rephrase that
those seem real obvious and yet I will
work with companies all the time
and see them in the planning process for
something and I'll say something like
well what is it you're trying to
actually do and they will have lost
their mission in the planning yeah right
they will have lost the mission in the
planning and I forget where we were
talking about this but it's the same
thing of thinking that the way we get to
the target is the mission it's not no
the way you get the target is not the
mission the way that you the way that
you execute the mission is not the
mission there's a big difference yeah
and so sometimes people get caught up in
the way they're doing something yeah not
what they're actually supposed to be
doing or even more important why they're
doing it yeah actually the whole thing
kind of seemed obvious
Kalea thing seems totally a lot of this
seems totally obvious and the reason
that it's important to go through it is
it doesn't seem obvious when you're in
it yeah when you're in it you miss
things and you don't pay attention to
things and that's what you have to be
careful of and you have to be careful
regardless of how experienced you are
because when you're experienced you get
experienced in a certain you get in
Syrian sin a certain category in a
certain rut I'll call it a rut you know
it's not necessarily bad but it's a good
word to use you know if you if every
jujitsu tournament that you go in
you've got great takedowns you get the
takedowns and you
pass guard and that's how you win that's
great and you can get used to that any
when you're preparing for a tournament
you bet yep I'm gonna work my guard pass
my work my takedowns and we all know
that there's gonna be someone that's got
better takedowns and you next thing you
know you're on the bottom and you're not
winning because you didn't prepare for
that you didn't think about that yeah
yeah and a lot of it seems like a almost
like a reminder for organization so you
know like something some people some of
us people will give us a suggestion to
be more organized in one way or another
yeah I've been aware of these things
it's possible and to some people some of
us it's like well you know like yeah you
know but the hey that's not my
methodology you know like it's it's
organized chaos kind of thing maybe
that's more of an excuse than anything
I'm not saying it always is but it could
be it's like it's a reminder a constant
reminder to indicate the value of being
organized in organized with everything
I'm not just saying your your pens are
over here you know in your paper so it's
not that specifically it's like the way
the way you're thinking about this whole
process I'm like where you are right now
given where you want to be yes and let's
face it when your world is disorganized
your mind is disorganized yeah and what
it takes what's something like this
you're actually making an excellent
point this type of this type of document
this type of process what it does is it
forces you to organize your mind yeah
that's what it's doing it's forcing you
to just it's to organize your mind and
even though your your mind may be
relatively organized and even though
your world may be relatively organized
there are still things and that takes me
back to like the rut idea there's still
things that when you approach them
you've kind of forgot or you've done
something a certain way which is within
the confines of what we're talking about
but now you're doing something else that
requires you to dig and and step outside
what you have been doing and if you
don't have anything to refer to you're
kind of
out in the wild yeah you don't want to
let your brain go out in the wild yeah
and that's a lot of times where the wind
distractions come in and like other
short-term things come in that you
attend to essentially yeah and yeah and
you know I'm gonna okay so I just said
you don't wanna let your brain go out
there in the wild and that's actually I
don't actually want to say that because
you do want you you do want to look at a
problem and you want to analyze a
problem with an open mind and maybe the
answer is wild yeah but we know that
discipline equals freedom right so if
you can't even put a structure around
what the mission is and what the problem
isn't and what the assets you if you
can't put a structure around that you
might as well do all your quote wild
ideas won't cover all the bases but if
you put a get a firm grip on what you're
actually dealing with well then you can
have some wild ideas yeah and that and
when you said don't let your brain go in
the wild it'd and I didn't get the
impression that you meant like stay so
rigid to this study didn't feel like
that it meant have a plan man you know
like even just I mean there's old this
is a common one where it's I can't plan
out your day or plan out your week or
whatever or even like it's kind of
applies to everything really like
anything that you want to do well it's
like you're gonna have some sort of a
solid plan that you know varying levels
of flexibility obviously depends on what
it is but like even if you wanna you
want to lose weight or you want to get
in shit you know you got a meal prep you
that worked out crap like you're gonna
know what you're gonna do unless you're
like one of these instinctive training
guys which is like way down the line
pretty much no one can do it but you
know like when you go in the gym like
you know I mean unless you don't know
what you're doing at all so that's like
another thing but again if you don't do
something well successfully or whatever
you couldn't have the workout yeah I got
burpees
I got pull-ups I got you know like I
typically know how many yeah you know I
even quite frankly we talked about this
a lot I even know how much rest I'm
gonna take in between you know so the
better your planned on
yes so anyway it's like a um I if you
have a plan yes but your brain going on
in the wild that's basically you're
saying don't not have a plan
you're just out in the wild you know
plan you know you need some kind of a
line to deviate from yeah that's exactly
what I'm saying yeah yes exactly right
so like you go to the gym right you got
your workout ok let's say today I got I
got flat bench then I got pull-ups and
then I got um you know some curls
obviously straight bar curls in fact I'm
gonna do that first so if I go in and I
go to the straight bar curl bar I do my
curls then it's time to go flat bench
barbell but it's like dang just like
someone using that right what plan done
the handover no right you better go jump
on the dumbbells jump on the iron you
got to do something yeah you got it you
got to explore that wild you know those
other options as flexible options so
yeah I dig it but yeah when you mean
like not having a plan that's that's the
wild you want to exist there yeah the
the other thing is if I mean if you
throw a dart with your eyes shut
completely right that's you don't have a
chance right yes but as long as you like
open an eye you go okay cool I kind of
see where we're going here boom now you
can make up now you can throw something
out in a while but maybe it hits check
you get to this point here where it is
identify tentative decision decisive
point decisive points good courts and
optional term decisive point is where
you you it's it's like a thing that
happens a point that you reach where now
you should win right now you have like a
marked advantage over the enemy
different for different situations you
know when you've got you know when Dean
Lister grabs ahold of your leg that's a
decisive point right I'm not saying
you're gonna lose but there's a strong
probability well let me do that me not
just group everyone in this I'll say
with me when Dean grabs my leg
I know I'm in trouble yeah
I can't get out but I know I'm in
trouble I know I'm gonna have to
scramble so those are that's what a
decisive point is and this is a very
interesting statement here identifying a
tentative decisive point and verifying
it during a course of action development
is the most important aspect of the
troop leading procedure the commander
visualizes a valid decisive point to
determine how to achieve success and
accomplish the missions purpose
the commander develops the entire course
of action from the decisive point
without determining a valid decisive
point the commander cannot begin to
develop an appropriate course of action
so that is a bold statement so to be
clear on the decisive point because
these kind of both make sense we're okay
it's it's not necessarily okay this is a
decisive point where we determine this
mission as successful it's not that it's
not achieving the mission you know it's
not an accomplishment okay it's we got
we just got to a point where now we
should win yeah like that we can
accomplish you know if you look at a
Stryker versus a grappler mm-hmm what's
the decisive point in that match you
know and you go to the ground
yeah the decisive point for the grappler
is when he gets the takedown the
decisive point for the striker is like
round two and a half and he stuffed four
takedowns and the fifth takedown attempt
it just gets brushed off like it's
nothing and all of a sudden and not and
now you see that now you see the
grappler breathing hard yeah so now so
now that now the strikers can start
upping the strikes and start teeing off
a little bit and start throwing kicks so
at that point and I've had those
discussions with fighters before like
okay like you're not throwing any kicks
in the first round
you're gonna you're not gonna put any
real weight behind your punches in the
first round second round I'll tell you
hmm
you know when once you've slough tauf or
stuffed three or four takedowns in the
first round to take down in the second
round decisive point just got reached
yes or throwing bombs same thing with a
grappler so those are the decisive
points in a fight you didn't necessarily
win just because that happened but
that's what you're setting up for so now
when we go into the planning we think
about that decisive point it's obvious
okay we got the guy the ground now now
we're good
that's what we plan around how do we do
that how do we make that happen
different fighter you know maybe it's a
fighter that doesn't do well against the
cage so we're gonna get him against the
cage that's not quite the decisive point
but that's a strategy we're gonna use
we're gonna get the other fighter
against the cage then we're gonna get
under hooks and we're gonna look to
grind and that's where the takedown
comes once the takedown comes in our
decisive point yeah so that's what it
means but it's very interesting that the
planning that they're talking about is
directed and related to that decisive
point not even to this getting the
mission done right that decisive point
hey once we get control of the you know
the external parts of this building and
we get it locked down we know what's
gonna happen I used to play this game
called zanuck on the original Nintendo
Nintendo Entertainment System you're
probably familiar with remember the old
school the cross you know it's not yeah
yeah anyway so is that like the original
like non joystick cuz the Theia that I
saw when I was a kid was the Atari did
you have a target area that was a I
didn't have one but I remember those
joystick sorry yeah battle tank or what
was it called it was called combat but
as a battle tank on Atari shoot the guy
eight spins you know no this is Nintendo
right Super Mario Brothers Metroid
you know gyromite remember these ones
duck hunt I didn't have a Nintendo sorry
what year was Nintendo I think he was 82
okay my work I'm very much in the game I
mean I should have had something but
whatever I guess we didn't get it over
at the Willy cow sold anyway for those
of us with there's this game called
zanuck and it's the typical you know
like a space invaders game right you
know how space invaders are yeah it's
like just the spaceship on the bus so
this one was way more dynamic you'd go
forward in any way but you could get all
these weapons right
so each weapon has like a number so if
you get a number one it's a certain
weapon and if you get another one it's
that same weapon but it's just stronger
or bigger or whatever right no one like
I think it was like level three or four
there's this any and then the thing is
the screen moves right so you don't you
don't move for the screen moves you just
got to keep up the speed you know it's
kind of that one of those Kenzi games so
there's this area in like level three
where if you it's this little smiley
face and you got to catch it you know
because if it passes it's gone you know
and you got to catch it it's a little
smiley face you got to shoot it and what
that does is any weapon you have it
gives it like the fullest power full
spar so if you get a number seven right
a number seven weapon which is like this
kind of one thing anyway it doesn't
matter but you get a lot a number seven
weapon and then you shoot that smiley
face it gives you like the most powerful
weapon in the whole game and you can
just it's super easy to just defeat the
whole game decisive point right there
that smiley face is the decisive point
just like how you're saying what's like
the plan when you play zanuck isn't to
beat the game it is overall yeah of
course but the plan really is to get to
seven and hit that smiley face that's it
have you ever thought about this
worthless knowledge that you have about
these games and how you could have spent
your youth studying important
philosophical things of nature well in a
way I did obviously where you're talking
about same thing sanic what is it zanuck
yes sanic yeah it wasn't like a super
duper popular game but it's pretty solid
you know this is good good good music
fun game hard okay so we're talking
about that's the decisive point decisive
point of that game where you should win
yes you still lose if you have yes in
seven level seven smiley face or
whatever yeah yes you lose
oh yeah cuz it just makes it super super
you get shot one time once you have that
you lose that lose the whole weapon yeah
exactly right not devastating when you
have that
what do you here's the thing like
compared to not having it it's like
night and day you know you know there's
a lot of games like that where you get
this super this one weapon that's
super rare but if you get it you know
it's like it makes it super easy usually
they don't last long like you know one
of those guns that like you shoot it
once and it kills everybody you know you
don't get a bunch of them this one you
get the seven it runs out but it takes a
lot to run out you know powerful what
very powerful decisive point hundred
percent yeah that's literally the
example of a decisive point in sanik is
there any other details you want to give
us one Super Mario Brothers trick you
can do while shouting you keep bouncing
on them and it gives you like infinite
men or something like that not infinite
but gives you like a hundred men that's
a decisive point you're probably gonna
win yeah cuz you can just die a bunch of
times just keep going to you and isn't
it sad though like they could have set
these games up so that they were really
teaching you something about something
right think of like some knowledge some
memorization you had to do to get this
thing about some important facts or
whatever some mental challenges that
made you think and you had to know and
yeah you learned whatever some history
or brother doesn't sound fun at all no
man can make if don't you think you
could make it fun
I'm sure yeah actually I think a lot of
the games now are kind of like that I
think I haven't played video games a
long time but I mean I don't think
there's any historical facts in Grand
Theft Auto five yeah all right let's
move on broke seriously ok so next step
once you've put your joystick away
develop initial commander's intent the
commander's intent is clear concise
statement of what the force must do to
succeed with respect to the enemy
terrain and desired end state which is a
set of required conditions that defines
achievement of the commander's
objectives you want to figure out what
it is you want to get done that's the
commander's intent the commander's
intent does not include the method by
which the force will get from its
current state to the end state the
method is the concept of operation and
this is obviously really important what
you want to let your troops do
is come up with a plan tell them what it
is you want to make happen and you let
them come up with a plan echo we're
going up Texas we're gonna film a
podcast it's gonna be underwater we're
gonna need four cameras because we got
four guests good that's it that's all
I'm gonna tell you now you're gonna
figure out what kind of housing and what
kind of tripod and how you're gonna do
it and what you're gonna run wires now
we're gonna talk when we remove mold you
hear all that stuff out a mission and
then analysis the mission a mission is
task and purpose clearly indicating the
action to be taken and the reason for
the action that's the mission task and
purpose clearly indicating the action to
be taken and the reason for the action
the commander must understand the
mission intent and concept of operation
one and two levels higher this
understanding makes it possible to
exercise discipline initiative and it's
kind of an implicit here that not only
must you understand the the concept of
operation and the intent and the mission
of one and two levels above you but man
you got to make sure you understand the
broad strategic mission as well everyone
needs to understand these things and the
classic example I'll use is when in in
the Battle of Vermont to think everybody
needs to know that what we're trying to
do is provide security for the populace
so everyone's got to have that in the
back of their mind when you're going out
and there's civilians and you know that
what you need to do is protect them
right you're making decisions based on
that
protecting the infrastructure like these
are things that you need to understand
even though that might not fall into
your your commander's intent or his
commander's intent or even his
commander's intent overall you've got to
understand what the vision is what the
strategic vision is of the entire
organization so if you've got a company
look and you know the company is
building the most critical thing of the
companies to build its reputation with
its clients okay guess what that means
everybody should know regardless of
little mission we're working on the
client is who we are there to support
you know that's where you get to like
the client is always right they come to
you and they say how we want this done
again okay let's make it happen everyone
can make decisions based on that so it's
not just one or two mission one or two
levels above you it's a lot more than
that and then what happens in this book
is they start to go into the analysis of
the terrain and weather and this is
where you just get into this absolute my
new show the five military aspects of
terrain obstacles they start you know
listing obstacles there's there's a page
of descriptions of existing obstacles
man-made include town canals railroad
embankments buildings power lines
telephone lines reinforcing obstacles
tactical tactical reinforces obstacles
inhibit the ability of opposing force to
move masse reinforce examples include
minefields conventional in situational
anti-tank ditches and obstacles and wire
obstacles and they go through each
particular thing that you might need to
think about and I'll throw this in for a
knee stump how will the terrain affect
the employment of mortars medium machine
guns and javelin missiles it's my
favorite Andy Stumpf weapon javelin
missiles
it's like a man pack missile that you
can use and it's usually used for like
destroying big things but it can also be
used in certain situations as an
anti-personnel weapon which Andy used it
for so they go through pages and pages
of all these things up and then they
start to talk about terrain and what's
interesting is if you I'm not gonna read
all the stuff but if you if you look at
this it shows you the level of detail
that they are asking people to think
through this information you know just
just page after page of terrain analysis
should produce several specific
conclusions listed below battles support
by fire assault fire positions
engagement areas and ambush sites
immediate immediate and immediate
objectives asset allocations
enemy personally goes on and on and on
and then it goes in the five aspects of
military weather visibility winds
precipitation cloud cover temperature
and humidity it just details each one of
those and then it goes into analysis of
the enemy jumping it through a little
section this analyzing the enemy answers
the question what is the enemy doing and
why the commander answers what is the
composition and strength of the enemy
force what are the capabilities of the
weapons and other systems what is the
location of current and probable enemy
positions
what is the enemy's most probable course
of action are they going to defend
reinforce attack withdraw delay and then
you start talking about assumptions
about the enemy and then you start
talking about the doctrinal analysis of
the enemy which is when you trying to
figure out how the enemy is going to
fight you then composition of the enemy
then disposition of the enemy then the
strength of the enemy then the
capabilities the enemy and then recent
activities of the enemy you see where
I'm going with this and you know what
that all boils down to a little bit of
sunsoo my friend sure knowing your enemy
know your enemy
know your enemy and what was the second
part you just said knowing yourself know
yourself so guess what the next section
is analysis of troops and support
available that's what you got then
you're gonna run through the same kind
of information what are the strengths
and weaknesses of subordinate leaders
hey I got you know three platoons six
platoons what do they like who are they
one of the strengths and weaknesses of
the leaders inside those platoons what
is the supply status of ammunition water
fuel of their necessary items what is
the present physical condition of the
soldiers what's their morale level what
does their sleep level what is the
condition of the equipment what is the
unit's training status and experience
relative to the mission - have they done
this kind of mission before what
additional soldiers our units will
accompany what additional assets are
required to accomplish the mission
so yes you gotta know yourself you've
watched The Princess Bride know
that's it's a surprisingly good movie
okay this is all fun pletely relative
let me tell me something know it what is
it about uh I should have asked you that
question okay is there a main point to
the story yes so there anyway there's
this guy he's the man in time is the
dreadful are here they're thinking they
want to learn they want to learn
something about leadership this movie
might have almost nothing to do with
that we'll give you an opportunity yes
it's like it's like a little metaphor I
guess a little bit if you understand it
as such so anyway this guy he's he's the
man in black is what they call him but
he's like the Dread Pirate Roberts
doesn't matter who he is but he
basically has to cut he gets a just I
forget he gets separated from this girl
that he loves whatever and then the
girl's gonna marry this evil Prince
mm-hmm so this guy comes back they
thought he was dead
whatever he comes back all trained he's
like a ninja almost it was like medieval
times kind of situation but he's like a
ninja he has a little black stuff or
whatever but he always when you when you
this guy was a complete planner when you
think about it when I'm listening to
this so there was a there's a part where
he gets like he gets real messed up and
he kind of wakes up or whatever and
these guys kind of help them and they're
like hey we gotta go like we gotta go
save this princess and I want to kill
this this guy this King or whatever and
the guy's like barely can walk barely
can talk he's like what's our assets and
then they're like okay we got this we
got this he goes what's our liabilities
and he goes blah blah blah and he and he
runs down exactly what you're saying
like what about what how they have they
have thirty man Bogardus Castle and he
was like just sitting there incapable of
moving mmm but he's planning like the
whole thing they need evaluating and it
goes I mean you know he comes up with a
plan but then when you think about the
whole past of the movie he plans like
the whole thing he planned like the
whole thing he one time he tricked the
guy right trick this guy he plays this
game he goes like this he goes uh here's
a one glass of wine for me one last wine
for you and he grabs them both and he
and he puts poison
iokay in powder puts poison in one of
them right and he goes okay you choose
choose which one is mine which one is
yours we both drink and whoever
wins lives so the guys like alright so
he like does some dumb distraction thing
it's a comedy movie and they know so
they both drink and of course the bad
guy dies right and then the girls like
right there so he grabs the girl and
she's like oh how did you do that he's
like oh they were both poisoned I spent
years building my immunity to this
poison I'm saying this guy was a planner
that's why he won okay
so you're a planner you'll probably win
planning is important very important as
is antidotes to whatever poison you're
talking you know my point is and has
always been these lessons are everywhere
sure if your eye is open there everyone
who's in that movie Oh Cary Elwes is his
name okay and I'm very fun we have a lot
of knowledge up in that brain of yours
that just has no real purpose you know
the Vsauce and never saw you know I know
the movie yeah but I've never watched
when it's the guy from the first song
okay more knowledge just thrown out
there for the world to me appreciate a
mental part of it next section analysis
of time available time available refers
to many factors during the operations
plan during the operations process plan
prepare execute and assess the four
categories that commander considers
include planning and preparation
operations next higher echelons timeline
enemy timeline I think about that enemy
timeline the important thing to think
about
can we move fast enough that we disrupt
their timeline we don't want to give
them time to set up that's another thing
that I didn't talk about when I talked
about the importance of time and
managing time and understanding time and
that you don't get a second chance with
time is that when you have an
opportunity to disrupt your enemy the
more time you give them the less
disruptive it will be that's why when
you're doing jujitsu and you you know
you know how the arm lock is there for a
second but then you you you don't go
because you're want wanting it to be
more perfect and then it's gone
and it also means when someone passes
your guard the time to escape that new
position is as soon as it happens not
when they get a breath and settle and
put the weight next section analysis of
civil convert considerations civil
considerations include the influences of
manmade infrastructure civilian
institutions and attitudes activities of
civilian leaders populations and
organizations within an area of
operations with regard to the conduct of
military operations and the questions
you ask are how do civilian
considerations affect the operation how
does the operation affect civilians how
does the company build national will in
its area of operations and and the
reason I'm I wanted to highlight that is
when we're making decisions you have to
think about the impacts beyond just your
team and the enemy team right so if
you're in business and you have the
opportunity to take out a competitor but
whatever that competitor employs a bunch
of people in a certain area and you take
them out well what does that do to your
reputation know how and you just shut
and I like that that's the kind of thing
you need to think about what think about
the other effects - for lack of a better
word the civilian population and it's
something in the military you get
trained very specifically to consider
all the time that's that's all I want to
bring it up some of the things that they
point out inside of the inside of the
civilian considerations ethnic dynamics
organizations of influence patterns
leaders and influencers which I know
you're one of those right an influencer
and then economic environment so those
are some of the things you need to think
about getting into the course of action
development course of action development
the purpose of a course of action
development is to determine one or more
ways to accomplish the mission
consistent with the battalion commanders
intent and you don't need to worry about
the commanders battalion intent if you
didn't get the mission from them but you
got to look at it
you've got anything you're trying to
achieve what various courses of action
can we utilize course of action is is is
really how do I want to use this word
fun but I always found the course of
action debate right cuz you got this guy
wants to do it this way and this guy
wants to do it another way and there's
always a little debate about how we're
gonna do this since I took so many
leadership lessons over the years from
watching or being a part of those
various course of action debates why do
you like it cuz it's all creative or
whatever cuz it's it's a real good
problem-solving trip yeah and it's also
a really good leadership drill because
you can watch the dynamics of yourself
and other people and when you know when
I say no this is the best way to do it
you're like no I like my way and we get
into a fight about it and all of a
sudden I'm like I'm ordering you to do
it my way and now you're pissed off and
it's like disaster so course of action
development is like a really cool
leadership experiment that happens and
on top of that it's a very cool problem
solving because you know there's more
than one ways to skin a cat and I'll
tell you that statement that I just made
is a very important statement to
understand there's more than one way to
skin a cat true statement and let me
tell you when you watch people develop
course of actions and try and select
them you would swear that there's only
one way because everyone has their way
and that's how they want to do it and
the reality is if you go into it
thinking hey you know what
Echo's way might be cool lace may way
might be cool Dave's way might be cool
doesn't really matter to me it's all
good if you go in with that attitude
you're already starting off on the right
foot let me put it to you that way if
you go in with oh I'm looking at this
problem and I see the premier solution
some of the some of the criteria for a
course of action should be suitable if
executed the course of action
accomplishes the mission legally and
ethically while consistent with the
battalion commanders concept and intent
that's like one of those obvious things
you're talking about like yes the course
of action should complete the mission
should be
feasible meaning the company has the
technical and tactical skills and
resources to accomplish the course of
action with the available time space
resources and availabilities that one's
real obvious acceptable military
advantage gained by executing the course
of action must justify the cost in
resources especially casually yes
distinguishable this one's a little bit
important if more than one course of
action is developed does it differ
significantly from the other solutions
so is it truly different or is it six
and one half dozen the other hmm and
believe me I watch people fight about
six and one half dozen the other all the
time and is it complete does the course
of action cover the operational factors
of who what where when why so those are
the things you're looking at then I
think as you pointed out earlier those
are some of the things that are just for
lack of a better word kind of obvious
and yet worth reviewing worth keeping in
your back pocket worth teaching your
subordinates might be real obvious to
you but your subordinates might not see
that as super obvious yeah analysis of
course of action begins with friendly
and enemy course of action and this is
where they start talking about using a
war game this is the and then they say
war gaming is the process of determining
what if factors of the overall
operations the object is to determine
what can go wrong and what decision the
commander likely will have to make as a
result so this is wargaming which is
saying hey what if this happens what if
that happens Andy and you have to look
at your course of actions and you have
to try and poke holes in them that's why
it's good not to have yes-men on your
team because if you come up with a plan
you got a bunch yes man they're just
like sounds great boss when what you
really want them to do is get out
daggers and try and stab that plan and
poke holes in it that's what you want
the best way for the commander to
wargame is to start at the company's
current location and go through the
mission from start to finish or started
a critical point such as the objective
or engagement so you'll break the thing
down phase by phase and say okay what
could go wrong here what could go wrong
here what could go wrong here and you
know what to do get challenged your team
you say look I think my plan is perfect
who thinks they could poke a hole in
this plan right give them a little
incentive to try and to try and poke
holes because otherwise they're gonna go
easy on you and you do not want that
goes onto a course of action comparison
and selection if the commander has
developed more than one course of action
the commander must compare them by
weighing specific advantages
disadvantages strengths and weaknesses
of each as noted during the war game
these attributes may pertain to the
accomplishment of the company's purpose
the use of the terrain the destruction
of the enemy or other aspect of the
operation that commander's believes the
commander believes to be important very
straightforward very obvious you take
your two it's funny how often you have
to actually say well let's figure out
which one is better you know if you're
right I mean even you know you're you
you were planning something with your
life and and someone has to say well
let's actually figure out which one of
these is the smarter way to do this
right this happens all the time
yeah you have to make that you know we
have to be conscious of that the command
and then at the step four by the way
we're on step four now the commander
initiates movement step fours initiate
movement the commander initiates
movement necessary to continue the
mission preparation order posture the
company for starting the mission yeah
Step five is conduct reconnaissance
right step five is conducted
reconnaissance what does that mean
you're gonna go and gather intelligence
you're gonna find out if you if the
intelligence that you're gathering
actually supports the plan that you've
come up with supports the other
information that you've been given
one thing that I'll say is sometimes
when we're not sometimes
conducting a reconnaissance is simply a
step in a certain direction right so
let's talk about the business world
let's say you want to move into a new
market area well yeah you can conduct a
reconnaissance by gathering data you
know oh well we think this is a good a
market area let's gather some data about
who lives there and what the demographic
is and if they align with what it is
that we're trying to do so that's that's
sort of gathering information right it's
not really reconnaissance yet but
sometimes just making a step in that
direction you don't necessarily have to
send out a recon element right you can
say okay you know I talked about this
you want to put a market you want to go
into this area put a kiosk out there
right put a kiosk out there and see what
kind of business the kiosk does before
you buy real estate before your rent
real estate before you hire them 14
employees to work in this air in this
building that you know for the kiosk
there see if there's any traction so all
I'm saying is sometimes instead of a
reconnaissance you're just taking a
small step in that direction and then
you're opening your feedback loop and
seeing if it supports the course of
action that you're planning to take yeah
wait so okay so for example you know how
like if you you want to know you want to
start a flower delivery service right
and it what it does is instead of
flowers you get fruit right I know
there's a company called like edible
something anyway let's say you have that
idea and then you instead of necessarily
looking oh is there a market the first
thing you do is you see if anyone else
is doing that already that's right it is
that like yeah that that's more to me
that's more like gathering intelligence
we're looking at data we're seeing who
else is doing this we google and we see
if anyone's delivering flowers that is
actually fruit which I guess is just a
whole thing thing yeah yeah that's more
that's more of an intelligence gathering
thing to me maybe a reconnaissance would
be
posting you know posting a website that
says you know fruit flowers here and
click here for more information are you
interested in fruit flowers and then you
see what kind of interest you get that's
not a great example I'm trying to think
of you know what you could do is you
could do the kiosk a yeah right put the
kiosk thing outside this supermarket and
say hey fruit flower bud food basket
flowers yeah so it's more it's so it's
actual it's almost like you're it's part
execution yeah that's what I'm saying
yes good way of putting it instead of
going full execution it's an iterative
decision-making process that I wrote in
leadership strategy in tax you're gonna
make a small step in that direction
that's what I'm trying to say these
small steps that you take are a form of
reconnaissance okay a small step of
execution is a form of reconnaissance in
many ways you know if you're if you're
gonna approach a target
well while you're approaching the target
look you sent a recon team in there
that's cool but then you send the
assault force in there well that's your
your gathering information you're not
necessarily going to 100% execute just
cuz you got on the ground you're gonna
move forward and go okay we're doing a
better assessment oh we're seeing what
kind of reaction we're getting received
the villages lights are still off so
that our target building isn't disturbed
all that is actually happening it's part
of the process
it is a reconnaissance even though it's
part of execution yeah kind of testing
the waters yeah so that's step five step
six is complete the plan you utilize
this information that you gather through
your reconnaissance or through your
minor steps of execution to complete the
plan and say yep this is gonna work this
is how we're gonna do it and this is
where it gets a little confusing because
now they're saying you issue the
operations order of what we're gonna
actually do so the op orde precisely and
concisely explains both the commander's
intent and the concept of how the
commander envisions the company
accomplishing the mission the orders not
contain unnecessary information the OP
Ord
is delivered quickly and in a manner
allowing subordinates to concentrate on
understanding the commander's vision and
not just copying what the commander says
verbatim
yeah the reason I said this is a little
bit confusing because we're kind of
trying trying to explain the fact that
execution can be a form of
reconnaissance well obviously if you're
gonna conduct an assault you're gonna
give a brief before you go on the
assault that's what this is so it kind
of out of that context it doesn't make
sense except for to say once you're in
the field you definitely you know you
get in a perimeter you're getting your
final area before you launch the assault
you'll say hey here's some changes
here's what we're seeing here's where a
guard post was that we didn't see before
so you can make some final planning
changes while you're in the field but
you've already issued your OP order at
that point it also says the commander
completes the order with a confirmation
brief at a minimum each subordinate
leader should be able to back brief the
company's mission and commander's intent
the immediate higher commander's intent
their own tasks and purpose and the time
they will issue their own units up board
so when you get done briefing and you
get done telling everyone what's gonna
do what they're gonna do and what you're
all gonna do then you have some of the
supportive leaders say alright what's
your mission echo alright what's your
mission life okay what's your mission
Dave even though I gave the brief of
what we're gonna do then I say okay echo
what do you guys don't you say up we're
gonna insert here we're gonna go there
and so everyone can kind of brief me
back not just what the overall mission
was not just what your mission does but
also the higher headquarters what the
higher headquarters intent is so I make
sure we all have a good idea around that
and then we get to the last of these
steps step eight supervise and refine
the final step of the troop leading
procedures is crucial after issuing the
out board the commander and subordinate
leaders ensure the required activities
and tasks are completed in a timely
manner
prior to mission execution supervision
is the primary responsibility of all
leaders both officers and NCOs must
check everything important for mission
accomplishment and I guess this is where
it you you take this and you take it one
step further to commencing the X
q ssin of the operation and you'll find
that you're gonna even once the mission
is starting its execution
you're still gonna supervise and
obviously you're gonna still we're going
to refine that mission as things unfold
so there's a very definitive separation
between planning and preparation but
it's pretty easy to take that planning
of preparation forward especially from
the perspective that just because we
made this plan doesn't mean we're not
going to very
leave the plan once we deviate from the
plan once we get in the field so it's
very important to understand that just
because you've launched doesn't mean
you've stopped refining the plan you
still need to refine the plan you still
make adjustments and you have to have
the humility to do that and you also
have to brief the team that look when we
get out there there may be some
adjustments that come and that is why it
is important that you don't make the
most rigid plan ever the most rigid plan
ever watch out for those rigid plans
those are not ideal and then we get into
this section the like the final section
which is preparations which security
operations I mentioned that and then we
get into rehearsals always under
emphasized rehearsals are critical they
don't even they don't really sort of
emphasize rehearsals as much as I think
they should they say and I'm not reading
the whole thing but it says commander
the commander uses well planned
efficiently run rehearsals to accomplish
the following reinforce training and
increase proficiency in critical tasks
that that's kind of not that big of a
deal right reveal weaknesses or problems
in the plan leading to more refinement
of the plan or development of additional
branch plans okay that is a big deal
that's a factually a huge deal and they
just say like it's number two right
reveal
some weakness oh man this is this is it
dude this is where you figure out
whether your plan is good or not by
running rehearsals and seeing what
happens and this is where you refine it
next is integrate the actions of
subordinate elements they're saying that
like that's no big deal
picture anything that you do in your
life and you're practicing it and then
someone else that you don't know shows
up to get in the game that's not easy
this there's stuff that needs to get
sorted out and they're just saying like
oh you're just gonna integrate that as
if there's any other way to do this
efficiently there isn't you got to
rehearse you got to have people walk
through how we're gonna do this next is
confirm coordination requirements
between the platoon and adjacent units
again we're just throwing it out there
we're just confirming there's some
things you didn't even know existed
until you did the rehearsal it's not
just confirmation there's actual things
you won't even figure out next is
improve each soldiers understanding of
the concept of operation the direct fire
fire plan anticipated contingencies and
possible actions and reactions for
various situations that may arise during
the operation this is hilarious to me
because it says improve the soldiers
each soldiers understanding I'm gonna
tell you right now you take someone and
set them through a brief those young
inexperienced soldiers SEALs Marines
they get done with that brief they don't
have a freaking clue you gotta take them
out and have them walk through this
thing before they understand it he'll
never mind those junior guys there's
some times where I look at the faces of
the senior you know some lieutenant and
even during the brief they don't really
they're briefing it hmm the platoon
chief is briefing it sometimes he
doesn't even understand exactly what's
gonna happen until you get out there and
rehearse it so they're acting like these
things are all additive like these are
sort of like oh yeah just a little icing
on the cake no I'm telling you this is
the cake this is the steak this is the
whole meal right here now it's not the
whole meal this is this is a vast
majority of the meal
it's not the drink but it's it's just
about everything else is it the main
course it's absolutely the main course
and they're making it like it's just a
little right yeah it almost doesn't
because that's one of those deals where
you know when you say oh rehearsals
that's like okay maybe if you're talking
about some play or some performance you
know they you need okay rehearsals are
sort of part of it traditionally but you
know even just like walkthroughs right
when you talk about those whatever it's
like you don't really realize the value
until you physically go through the
situation then you're like oh damn this
is night and day because just like how
you saying like like your junior
officers or whoever when they're like oh
yeah I got it I got it the brief I got
it all good then when you go out there
and when you the first walkthrough when
it's like oh wait no we don't got it we
got to work on this thing I was talking
on EF online the other day and I was
explaining we were talking about I had
done a whole thing I'm a fact I've done
a whole thing about narcissism and how
narcissism like we all know that's bad
but if you read the traits of being a
narcissist
you'll read through maybe like oh that
one stings a little bit oh that one
stinks oh I've done that before because
there's things it's like it's your ego
right it's an extreme ego so we all have
an ego and that means that we all have
some traits of a narcissist and when you
read those traits and you start paying
attention to me like okay it just it's
another tool to assess your own ego yeah
you want to know a trait and this this
was because yeah I read about narcissism
for whatever reason I mean that's why
but I do so um I even know the methods
to deal with narcissism as well there's
like a psychological probe and that's
the thing I actually had to break it
down because I started getting asked
questions and I said listen I'm not
talking about a a technically just
technically um assess like this person
is an actual full-on narcissist right
right there's a different methodology
that you have to I'm talking about just
hey you're kind of normal
run-of-the-mill
big ego person that
you know we're in charge hey you know
you need to listen to me yeah and so
that's it so so that's the kind of
narcissist I was talking about what are
you talking about yeah the real deal one
yeah like clinically diagnosed
narcissist person I don't know if that's
an actual thing or not but like a foot
that like a real narcissist anyway so
one of the like the tell-tale signs and
it's not in the trait list of traits
it's more like on online ok so there's
ways to deal with narcissism right and
there's ways not to deal with it so um
and I'm not gonna leap into that part of
it but one of the ways not to deal with
it is to tell them hey you're a
narcissist because only a real narcissus
has an element of pride with their
narcissism so they'll be like oh yeah
cuz a real gnosis literally can't see
why like they're not correct in the way
they're thinking about themselves
disturbing it's like they for real think
that everyone else sees the same thing
as they do you know it's like it's
literally that's what they think so when
you tell if you are narcissists I was
like hey echo you're such a narcissist
your reaction would be on the if
regardless of what I'd say and how I
behave on the inside I would feel like
oh yeah cuz I'm dope like I'm just I'm
just seeing the truth really about
myself like no you guys see it too no
matter what you guys are just hating or
whatever that's what I would feel about
it I wouldn't feel very they're jealous
yeah you know as far as like the
differentiator is a can or mille person
if someone's like hey like you're kind
of a narcissism a normal person would be
like like don't call me that like I'm
not a narcissist on the inside they'd
feel that regardless of how they'd
behave be real arsonist is like of
course I mean yeah you're jealous of
course I am because look I'm better than
you yeah cuz he exactly right so it's
like they of course they don't care
about the language you know the because
you call narcissus big ego you think
you're better than everyone you can say
all those things they all mean the same
thing to a narcissist it means like well
yeah I think that because that's true
like everyone knows that kind of a
feeling on the inside you know
regardless of what they say or do yeah
so anyway again that's like how not to
deal with a narcissist you know how like
like if you if I were to be like hey
chuckle you're freaking
you're a dear you give up too easy or
something like that right sometimes that
helps people when you're like hey you
just you just give up too easy or you're
kind of like you're just being
weak-minded or whatever like yeah sure
their ego will be like screw you but
they might go home and think about it
because I don't want to be weak-minded I
don't want to be I don't want to give up
too too early you know but a narcissist
it's the same thing it's like hey you're
not that you shouldn't be narcissistic
like this kind of thing right it's
essentially trying to help them but the
thing is it like adds fuel to the fire
I'm saying so you can't like you
literally can't deal with a narcissist
like that so how do you deal with it oh
there's all kinds of techniques give me
like one positive technique pause or one
one actual technique it's called gray
rocky what does that mean so gray rain
is kind of like it's basically letting
all their what all their techniques just
fall and not get a reaction from you why
is it called grey rocking because I'm
like super forgettable super like you
don't get so an hour cyst basically gets
their power from your response so if you
don't give them a positive or negative
response you just give you're like oh no
office normal face yeah
but not even over doing that yeah like
an appropriate response and then that
sort of it you know so it's yeah it's
called gray rock there's all these weird
take on like that in names yeah I like
that it's surprising it works very well
too by the way
yeah that sounds like a good way to deal
with it you're not adding fuel to the
fire
nope in fact you're extinguishing the
fire because fuel to the fire is
positive or negative reaction it's any
reaction anything that feeds the idea
that like what I say and do affects the
world so hugely you know so this person
getting mad or happy or impressed or
whatever like any like strong reaction
it's like hell yeah I'm gonna keep keep
it up whatever I'm doing you know track
the reason I was talking about
narcissists well the reason that we're
talking about it because I was
explaining that I talked about it on EF
online
and then I went back and talked about
the next session I talked about well we
talked about narcissism and egos too big
but we seldom talked about you know lack
of confidence and the reason that we the
reason that I lean towards talking about
staying humble and checking your ego the
reason that I'd lean towards that is
because that's the majority of the time
that's the problem
why because I'm talking to leaders and
how did leaders end up in leadership
positions because they had confidence
and so the tendency is that confidence
is gonna grow out of control it's not a
tendency that someone gets to a
leadership position through confidence
then all of a sudden falls apart that
can happen it does happen you can also
get young leaders that are getting put
into a leadership position that lack
confidence so sometimes you do have
people they're confident gets hurt their
confidence doesn't exist and you have to
improve their confidence so I was
talking about various things where you
want to improve the confidence of
yourself or the confidence of your
subordinates and one of the things that
I talked about like let's say you have a
subordinate that has to present and
they're not gonna be presenting they
they blue they blue another gig where
they were supposed to be presenting to a
client and they messed it up and now
their confidence is shot that worried
about talking but so you've got a job of
getting them trained up so one of the
things I talked about this going back to
rehearsals which is where we got there
in the first place is you know I said
you make them rehearse you know / to do
your presentation to me echo and then
what I say is hey echo now you're gonna
do your presentation and I'm gonna you
know make something go wrong mmm whether
it's I you know I turn off your
presentation right you got slides up
there I just turn it off and you just
react to it and you and what you'll do
is you'll come up with a standard
operating procedure where you know the
slides go black and you go oh it looks
like I got some technical difficulty let
me take a second to try and figure this
out instead of not knowing what to do
with it becomes a brain lock situation
or and then I'll also make you you don't
mess up mess up a word must mess up the
pronunciation of a word so when you're
trying to say flag instead of saying
flag you say Flicka and you're like hey
you know we want to make sure we put up
the right Flicka you're gonna have to
excuse me on that I don't know we know
where that word
came from but there it is I meant to say
flag so you just rehearse what you're
gonna say when you mess up and that way
when you mess up you're ready for you're
a little more ready for it so so this
idea of rehearsals being sort of a
additive measure because I'll tell you
what if you were doing a presentation
and I ran you through these drills you
wouldn't just be a little bit better if
something went wrong you would be ten
times better in handling that situation
you've already been there you've already
seen it so rehearsals are something that
you as a leader should focus on to such
a high level because they are so
beneficial not just as an additive but
in actually bringing together and
consolidating the plan inside of
people's heads how they're gonna react
what they're gonna do during various
contingencies it is a powerful tool and
in the SEAL Teams what we used to say
was one-third planning one-third
preparation one-third rehearsal
the Army has something was it what it's
like one-third two-thirds which is
one-third of the time planning and then
the other two-thirds are four people to
what do they say prepare and prep or so
I guess listen to say figs but they
don't put that as big as an Phasis in
that in that saying as we did which is
one-third planning one-third preparation
one-third rehearsals maybe they mean
that inherently but we actually say it
in the SEAL Teams that's what yeah cuz
when you think about it and I sort of
realized this when you're when you talk
about like training whether it be police
or any or even fighters and stuff like
that where if you think of high-level
performance like industries will say the
NFL was saying write millions of dollars
per person by the way NBA whatever think
about their situation it's like how much
of their time do they spend actually
performing very little prepare to train
in a paradigm so they're training all
day every
day off season springtime no matter you
know the seasons what 13 games long
mm-hmm meanwhile their training training
training training training training and
then what kind of training do they do
it's all rehearsals essentially I mean
sure there's some academic stuff for
sure but as far as when you go to
practice as a football player basketball
player what are you doing through our
rehearsals all day going full-speed
actually but it's all rehearsals and
they're doing that
it's probably like a ten to one really
ratio what is the ratio of rehearsals
versus scrimmage right but okay so
scream me because those are two
different things that we have to admit
right now yeah kind of it depends on
what you mean but cuz re a scrimmage is
like a it's like an active rehearsal
okay because you're all practice is for
a game that's it
that's what it is you got the game
that's the performance part of it like
in Indonesia you know your situation
it's a mission an operation or whatever
everything else is training so scrimmage
is yet so rehearsal but is just more
dynamic it's like with a resistant enemy
you know and then there's like a
walkthrough which is kind of maybe like
more than like a rehearsal yeah yeah
because you got to do all right
oh you've gotta be ready for that you
got to be ready for that real
interactive would you say enemy you got
to be ready for someone that's actually
gonna give you resistance just like
jiu-jitsu you got to learn the move you
got to drill to move that's a rehearsal
but then you got to do the move in
actual situations so that you're ready
to use it in a fight yeah and then you
got what's called the dress rehearsal I
guess that's more with like plays and
stuff right dress rehearsal yeah we do
everything the way it's gonna be yeah
yeah see I'm saying so it's all cut it's
all sort in the same bucket you know as
training but it sets essentially you're
going through the motions as close as
you can to the real deal you know and
actually it's a spectrum really
sometimes it's like you just go through
walkthroughs yeah right that's a big one
exactly we do that in the military you
uh go do walkthroughs you don't you
don't have your weapon with you yes in a
pair of shorts and you're walking around
like where we tape out the shape of the
building we're gonna hit and everyone
walks around okay this what we do you're
you know they're you know but then we
will do sometimes like the next level
hey bring your
so now you got every one of the radio
arts we're gonna make little comps and
then maybe you'll do like some
walkthroughs with your weapon you're
probably not gonna get fully kitted up
but you will do once you're kid it up
like a full inspection yeah and that's
actually the next section of this yeah
but at the end of the day though to your
point is it's all rehearsals really even
like the role play stuff that you say
what's the whole nother thing but it's
yet another form of a rehearsal oh for
sure role plays another former rehearsal
yeah yeah oh you're saying that it
during a role play you might not know
the outcome you have a little bit of a
resistant the opponent will say yeah
yeah that is that as a rehearsal to
rehearsal of problems and this is what I
was just getting to his pre combat
checks and pre combat inspections is the
last thing pre combat checks and pre
combat expections
are critical for the success the
missions pre combat checks and
inspections must be tailored to the
specific unit and mission requirements
one of the best ways to ensure pre
combat checks and pre combat inspections
are complete and thorough is with echo
charles full dress rehearsals so there
you go that is something that you know
takes it to the next level and then
after the Versalles obviously you've
done with your brief and that's the last
step and now we are going to execute and
that's it that's you know a quick
run-through of this document that's one
section of this one document and like I
said these are some good guidelines
they're definitely good things to think
about you can use them as a framework to
think through how you assess and how you
decide courses of action and how you
communicate up and down the chain of
command but you're gonna you know you
listen to this and it allows you to sort
of customize these thought patterns to
make them fit what it is that you do
more specifically but I will say it is
good even though these things seem
obvious it is good to write them down
and put together some kind of a
checklist that you can go through so you
don't miss things and so that when you
have a subordinate that you bring on
board that you
want to take your job which is your goal
to work yourself out of a job
how much easier does it make the process
to say all right here's the 14 things
that we think about while we're doing
this phase of planning boom there you go
and I'll tell you what when you write
stuff down when you develop curriculum
when you develop standard operating
procedures and then you share those you
get better at them so that will allow
you to go out execute properly and get
the job done speaking of getting the job
done echo Charles yes no we're we're all
out here trying to get the job done on a
personal level as well we're trying to
hold the line we're trying to stay on
the path can you help us yeah sure I can
tell you what I do
that'll help that'll be that'll help so
we are I am we are very disciplined with
our dosages of joint warfare krill super
krill and now the D vitamins I'm going
I'll dit not all day but every day every
day how many of those you take I say one
of the morning one at night yes what are
you doing - boom
more with the mix okay just to one hint
in the morning when we're good to go yes
so man this is this is a good one and I
said this plan anytime before but I'll
say it again it's a big deal where tre
take joint warfare and krill oil mmm
consistently go one month I don't know
two months whatever and then try to get
off it okay yeah Dean I'm sure but a
really critical and impactful should I
say proving scenario because I'll get
off it because of whatever you know I'll
forget one day or I'll be like oh I
forgot to do it I'll do it later and
then you know whatever and then before I
know it it's like Brad like two weeks I
got a question for you bro yeah why
don't you just put the supplements that
you take by your toothbrush and when you
wake up in the morning and brush your
teeth before you brush your teeth you
take your hitters as needed and then
also before you go
a bed at night you brush your teeth you
take what you're supposed to take I
don't even understand why we're having
this conversation you're a 40 year old
man I'll tell you what happened when I
tried to do that and I say try it like
are you your are than 40 aren't you yes
sir how old are you and you know that's
classified
it's 42 14 42 you're a 42 year old man
even worse I know but it's bad do you
brush your teeth every day yes yes oh
why not just add this step okay that
takes an extra 20 seconds yeah well it
takes someone 20 seconds this is why
because look if I'm gonna if I'm gonna
sort out that what do you call put them
put them out whatever like lay them out
like a whole salmon stage there that's
taking the stage okay yeah so yeah I
don't really like pouring out the night
before no okay eat eat eat eat or done
and so I started doing that but I'm like
okay I'm gonna keep these bottles in the
back room with my toothbrush because
that's sort of not where they go in my
house before in the cat bit right I know
I know house but I'm just saying this is
what happened to me when I went through
that process I was like well it doesn't
make sense it you know I go downstairs
anyway to the cabinet every day
so apparently not okay no see I not see
you talking about the reality of it I'm
saying well this is what happened so
anyway I was like okay for me to stage
them by my tooth worth two to three took
more work than me remembering that you
know in the morning when I come down so
I just stopped doing it then of course I
forgot to but the last now you're
teaching a lot of people right now
oh yeah cuz Brett I'm extra step okay
yes what am I your toothbrush now this
is what I did so okay so you know I have
this wine down routine at night and a
big part of it is cleaning like the
whole kitchen just cleaning it whether
it's messy or not messy just clean as
part of the routine
nightly right so I put everything away
so if I leave those bottles out it's
like I didn't really clean I'm I'm not
saying this is what I'm thinking at the
time I'm thinking back on it OCD so
nothing
trust me if you knew the actual process
it's not OCD at all but if I'm just like
hey I'll clean the kitchen sure but I'll
straight-up just leave those out leave
those out right there at the on the
counter so it's essentially staging just
like you did but just not with my
toothbrush just at the counter where I'm
going anyway in the morning every single
morning see I'm saying anyway that's
what I start to do
it's i am i believe with 100% certainty
that that achieves what you're achieving
with the station about you do okay and
yet you do not achieve 100% certain I'm
on it now though I have been for a
little bit and brother
seriously the difference is night night
and dangerous you think sometimes
sometimes really when you're like in the
game or whatever and maybe you don't
crush your joints or nothing like that
like you can kind of get by like you can
like I'll just walk I was just warm it
up a little bit this do this shoulder
right here it's just this little real
specific part I look I get that right
there too if I do this is a specific
weighted dips I get this all yeah oh
yeah yeah it's we yeah it's weird it's
like this weird little specific spot and
yes with specific exercise which is like
when I do shoulder press it doesn't hurt
as much as if I do incline press which
is really weird this is really shrink
the shoulder but either way it's like
I'll just warm up some more maybe rub it
you know rub it and stretch it out more
or whatever and then when you go back on
the joint we're in the krill oil you're
like opera I don't even have to like do
all that anymore
you know I'm saying just like a
prediction and then and then so if you
just apply that to your whole thing it's
like well why not
you should consistently be on that keep
you in the game big time
I recommend instead of cleaning your
kitchen staging in your kitchens that
when you go downstairs inevitably then
you can decide oh yeah it's time for me
to take my supplementation I recommend
in between your toothbrush and your
toothpaste there it is get it done no
factor but yeah yeah I can dig it I can
do it but hey whatever your method are
you a little OCD no I don't think what's
the wind-down routine that you're
cleaning your kitchen I think it's just
like a like that's just how you know you
know when you do something over and over
and over again it's just like it's
almost like more
habet then what if it's like a long day
and you've been editing a hard rigorous
hard-nosed little day yeah still yeah
you still will just get it done
yeah no matter what I think it's like
the process though you know how like you
know like kids you they want a bedtime
story
you don't meet a bedtime somebody asked
me like well you know how do you think
how did you figure out but why do you to
post stuff on social media and I was
like oh because I'm just a creature of
habit that's what I that's what I that's
a habit that I have right now that's
what I'm good yeah yeah great like
whatever strategy yeah like I'm doing
this for this yeah exactly like this
strategy but I guess clean the kitchen
is both because it's like functional as
well yeah in the kitchen
but I support it yeah so yes that's what
we're getting at take some
supplementation join warfare krill oil
take your vitamin d3 you know and you
know that way maybe some cold war let's
say I take the cold war yeah you know
it's interesting I take the cold war
during the day mm-hmm sure okay so
anyways get on that also we got
discipline go in cans we got discipline
going pills we got discipline going
powder if you need that little
psychological hitter to keep you rockin
in relevant as well bulk to if you need
some protein or if you just want dessert
because let's face it sometimes you just
want dessert oh yeah speaking of which
okay so I see these videos that Pete in
them and origin are putting out and it's
like the Moke bar factory set up or get
out of it yeah cuz I've had monk bars
before yes and like for those kind of a
game-changer right big it's a big deal
yes so it you know like okay so I like I
like these candy bars I don't eat them
all the time actually I barely eat candy
bars you know like most things with
peanut butter is gonna be you know my
kind of go-to when I do go to those so
those are kind of like a dessert right I
mean
you think of desert as I call you scream
or some pie or something like this but
to me a candy bar is what's your
favorite candy bar anything Reese's
actually there's these things called
Reese's sticks they're kind of like a
wreath they're Reese's you know so this
can get a better chocolate but they're
like you know what KitKat is so you know
those are one of my go-to when I was a
kid okay so it's like the more room you
want iced KitKat tasted cool in your
mouth I'm not gonna hot summer right but
it's like you know the the makeup of a
KitKat it's like that but just more
robust and it has the Reese's of peanut
butter and chocolate
that's right now my favorite one but
nonetheless if you get a multi are you
know it's essentially it's not a Reese's
stick because it's made of different but
it's a straight-up candy bar straight up
and it tastes like a candy bar
yeah and here's the test bro you know we
all have kids varying level varying
levels of age mmm and so my son is three
before later this year whatever Terrence
and that's like if he doesn't like if
he's like hey this isn't a candy bar
this is a health bar yeah cuz it's not
like he's unfamiliar with candy bars
right eproms candy bars wouldn't if he
gets the opportunity or whatever right
he'll sneak he'll see where I put the
mote bars in the freezer by the way
which is another strategy he'll see
where I put he's three three years old
easy and he'll go steal them up are
straight-up steal them anyway so these
are legitimately dessert things items
that are protein well they're not out
yet
we apologize we're working on it yeah
and everything here plus the chocolate
white tea Mulk warrior kid milk you can
get it all at the Vitamin Shoppe or you
get it origin Maine dot-com you get it
on Amazon - yeah just good so it's it's
out there also
jiu-jitsu stuff you just do slowly
getting back into it everybody everybody
got it okay you know it's one of those
things you sort of gotta what are they
we call essential activities yeah I mean
releases certain policies I guess it's
like you know where you
figure out how you can roll with ya in
your Corning team yes yeah fully and
then what you got channellock we're good
yep good to go so you get Aggie if you
don't have one already or even if you do
have one already to get or Jinky men in
America 100% and they're the best Gees
100% are those related made in America
the best maybe maybe not
nonetheless I think I'm leaning towards
yes yeah so actually no there's like
what do you call it the the sum is
greater than the it's part of the
greater than the parts
yeah or whatever because it's like made
in America that's something it's the
best that's something and it's the best
because it's made in America so the fact
that it's made in America makes it even
more of the best you seem saying all
right I agree with your logic we're not
following it but I like the outcome okay
here here you go I'll put a finer point
on it if Pete grabbed one of his looms
probably more than one went up to
Washington State right at the border of
Canada and made one of those keys that
gear would still be the best gear should
still be the best but it wouldn't be
better than the one made in America
because it's not made America you seem
saying so it's the best regardless but
since it's made in America it's even
more the best assume saying got it
that's what I'm saying
anyway no less or domain.com you can get
these things plus denim jeans you know
again made an America same deal 100%
same deal plus boots plus t-shirts plus
hoodies plus beanies but I just all kind
if you need something check it out you
might want to get something you might
wanna get something that's made in
America without compromise
very true which is a bold statement
that's what we're doing yep also Jocko
has a store Jocko store.com this is
where you can get more stuff apparel if
you will shirts t-shirts hoodies hats a
lot of stuff back in stock man so you
can get them now straight up I know I
know
in the past we've been sold out of this
or that or whatever it's it's not like
that anymore things are changing on the
jungles data positive or in a positive
way their impact dough is sticky
stepping up his game they're improving
yes so anyway do you want discipline
equals freedom you know things where you
want to represent like
on the path while you're on the path and
you want to represent a hardcore deaf
core that's this is where you get the
stuff chocolate or calm I like the way
you did that well you know it's one of
those things it's true also subscribe to
this podcast if you want to go and leave
some reviews if you want to don't forget
about some other podcasts that we've got
including the thread which will be back
soon it with a new name which I've
already thought of we have the new name
we have to make some final refinements
to the new name but I think we're gonna
like it we also have the grounded
podcast we got the warrior kid podcast
we got warrior kids soap from Irish Oaks
ranch calm also on the jaw closed or
calm made by a warrior kid who owns his
own business at age 13 making something
that's not just a business product but
is something that every person can use
so that they can stay clean
don't forget about a youtube channel
because echo is putting all kinds of
time and effort into YouTube videos amen
are you gonna put some kind of a special
effect into this video that we're
talking about no man I don't know you
know there's mixed emotions about a lot
of people that think that this right
there is the best idea you know that
anyone's had a long time is to
occasionally throw in a some kind of a
cool effect into this video yeah yeah so
people are watching and they're like
yeah don't you think the world could use
that right now you know I do yeah
apparently you're undecided I'm telling
you the world could use some some
special effects in this video that I'm
making right now it's kind of a nuanced
I should elation put my hand at you and
it just said fire into your eyes yeah
well yeah maybe maybe not I don't know
some people say that hey man no effect
or enhancement needed that's you know
some of the word I I've been getting
okay so not maybe not needed but would
be nice I'm not talking about like
something crazy I'm talking about
occasionally
there's something happens or I say
something
or you say something and it merits a
little highlight so this is okay and
actually I I gotta think of what to do
but okay this is what I did some I tried
it like learn new dumb things and CGI
wise so I have this this program it's
pretty extensive programs like 3d
modeling and stuff but I just came
across whatever it's the thing that
allows you to do more stuff that it's
facial recognition so don't recognize
your face create like a mask you know
those masks that you know you just sort
of put on or whatever a mask and you can
talk he can whatever it'll take all that
data and create a mask and then you can
put like your real face on the mass so
it looks like a talking face of your
mask you can incorporate that into your
video I don't know isn't a talking face
of your stalking mask of your face isn't
that just your face yeah but so why is
it even cool because now I'm just saying
there's a bunch of things you can do
with it but one of the things for
example I could get your talking face
and then I could make a video of you
talking whatever I want you to say and
then I can incorporate that floating
mask what do you call a disembodied face
of jaakko in the video somewhere now or
you know anytime I do like I'm trying to
describe some event unfolding and
there's a couple people talking and I
say so this guy says you don't want to
do that and then someone else's yes I do
so you could all put in guessing body my
face we can be having a conversation
with myself
yeah maybe put a little bit of uh you
know something that makes the face just
a little bit different but it's still me
sure yeah see I use a little creativity
breath you can make something happen
thank you don't forget about we have
psychological warfare little
psychological haters to help you over
any potential pitfalls of discipline you
might encounter we also have flipside
canvas comm run by my brother Dakota
Meyer if you need a little visual
something to keep you nudged onto the
path
then go to flipside canvas comm
made-in-america question made in America
yes answer also got a bunch of books the
code leadership strategy and tactics
field manual warrior kid one two and
three
Mikey and the Dragons discipline equals
freedom Field Manual how to get after it
extreme ownership and that I kata me of
leadership we got a salon front which my
leadership consultancy and what we do is
solve problems through leadership EF
online this is it this is live we got a
new version up right now we got a new
platform and I know you like that word
Echo Charles we got a new platform which
is way more dynamic we got a really
awesome forum on there so you got
leadership problems you can connect with
the brigade of people that are on EF
online exchanging ideas
the instructors all the instructors are
on there we're all getting after it
we're doing live events several times a
week where you can communicate you wanna
ask me a question just you yeah Twitter
will work I may get to it come to EF
online
ask me the question let me see your your
disembodied head on the zoom meeting
asking me a question we can talk about
it go to EF online.com for that we got
the muster next one is a phoenix arizona
september 16th and 17th Dallas Texas
December 3rd and 4th go to extreme
ownership comm for details and look
we're probably gonna have to implement
some social distancing in there so we're
gonna have less tickets to sell so that
means they're gonna sell out faster so B
if you want to come come to go to
extreme ownership calm for that we have
EF overwatch calm where we have
individuals from the Special Operations
community ready to go to work in the
civilian sector go to EF overwatch calm
if you're on either side of that
equation
America's mighty warriors dot org
this is mama Lee Marc Lee's mom and she
has made her mission in life to help
service members their families gold star
families around the world on deployment
here in America if you want to donate or
you want to get involved on some level
go to America's mighty warriors dot org
and if you haven't had enough of my
bland blathering or you just just could
use a little bit more of echoes die
aggressive declarations then you can
find us on the interwebs on Twitter on
Instagram and on Facebook echo is out a
quote echo Charles and I am at Jocko
willing into all the military folks out
there thank you for your service day
after day night after night week after
week month after month year after year
protecting our way of life and our
liberty and to all the police out there
and law enforcement and then the
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service you
all do a job that is underpaid
underappreciated and over demanding and
we thank you all for protecting us here
at home and everyone else out there you
know I talked a lot about planning today
we talked a lot about planning today
collaborative planning in parallel
planning and distributed planning and I
talked timelines and courses of action
and analysis of the enemy and all those
elements but listen the planning means
absolutely nothing without execution so
yes come up with a plan think through it
make sure it makes sense and then go out
there and get after it and until next
time this is echo and Jocko thanks for
joining us out